the hailstones are returning to camp
from a hunting trip
but without a market to guide them along
the treacherous River their path home is
uncertain you see how hard that was this
is just inches off the surface of the
water see how much trouble that was to
figure out where we were that's why it's
kind of fudging along here thinking I'm
gonna take it slow till I know exactly
where I'm going we were having trouble
out in the lagoon trying to find the
most to the river we came in really well
over the sandbars it's these real high
tides that took away the marker that was
here I was wood that was staked down in
here and it had Jerry Jones read Jerry
Jones hanging on it and you can see it
for miles it's gonna be this point has
receded quite a bit the old markers
fallen over the absolute best thing we
can do for ourselves and other people
probably put a marker here I mean him
know how to get into this River in this
area without any landmarks or anything
but for the kids to learn and to be
comfortable with coming here it's good
for them to have something to aim for
and be hey I know where I'm at
I want to put a tower here with use
tower for multiple uses we can use a
parade taking ourselves to come in we
can use it to orientate ourselves in the
wintertime when it's snowing or when
we're traveling and it's foggy and we'll
also be able to get up in it and look
over to see if the ocean is rough and
maybe even see a seal or two if they're
popping up around here shouldn't take
too long to dig and chop and tie
something together that you'd be very
very useful to everybody around here